do you remember the first day of your
reality show career remember the first
day he walked in was it back in 2000 I
absolutely do the very first day that I
worked in reality television I was on a
reality show called fear for MTV we were
at La Center Studios working in post I
was a logger transcriber which meant
that I was going to basically do
transcription of all of the field
content for the benefit of the story
producers I showed up to work I got the
immediate glamour dosage as I walked
into the elevator in Jennifer Love
Hewitt and the security guard were in
the elevator at the studio went up to
the office got acquainted with everybody
and the first night that I spent was 7
p.m. to 3 a.m.
logging and transcribing footage of
people having supernatural encounters in
a building in the middle of downtown
that was dead empty in the middle of the
night so I spook easily so it was a
rough start a rough start but good
people to start with so what was your
idea of this industry like coming you
graduated from Full Sail right and and I
think you drove across country right so
knowing that a lot of it is sort of this
grunt work to start out what was your
over the next few months what was your
impression of the industry knowing that
this could be my life for a few years
mmm well originally I had moved to
California thinking that I was going to
be a screenwriter and movies are where
it was at and I had tons of specs
written and I was just gonna take
meetings and meet people this was going
to be temporary reality television I
came at the perfect time because it was
really just sort of being reborn in the
format that it's in now this is mm
you're talking about you know survivor
came out that year a lot of the key
shows that really changed the game came
around right as I was here and I started
to realize things like this is not
something that is seasonal like they'll
do one or two seasons of a show a year
you can start in March or you can start
in November like why wouldn't I want to
work in a business that was year-round
instead of worrying about getting a job
once a year and then if I missed
staffing or I couldn't sell something
that I would just
to sit at home and suddenly it started
looking really attractive just from the
perspective of a Canova of a paycheck
that didn't quit and so did that dream
die in terms of wanting those scripts to
be made for film or television for
sitcoms or did you see a new form of
creativity take place with reality TV
how did that shape for you
the thing I always tell people about
story is anything you know about story
can be applied to reality television
it's just that you're sort of retro
actively assembling the refrigerator
magnets in order to create a coherent
story I had studied very hard had
studied screenplays that worked I was a
big said field devotee as I still am and
that was how I learned to write so you
know adapting that for reality
television and understanding what real
story has to mimic in order to be
interpreted as story it wasn't that much
of a transition for me and I don't feel
that that dream died and outside of the
fact that I think that screenwriters and
television writers it's a little sexier
I think when a student film students
want to get into the business they're
not talking about reality television
even though it's half or more of what's
on television they're thinking about
movies and TV shows because there's a
perception of glamour that goes with
that the reality is very different
because the only thing that matters in
the end is are your checks clearing are
you telling stories that you're not
embarrassed to tell are you building a
body of work and and I am doing all
those things from reality television as
are my colleagues we're just not getting
the the same the same buzz we don't get
we don't get quite as much attention at
the punch bowl at parties
you